awesome to see sean o'malley um
you know he's just an entertaining guy
uh and you know
he's trying to you know add to his
knockout resume
chris moutinho was the guy who fought
him and
the guy that was one of the most
exciting parts of the night was when
that guy took just kept taking the hits
from
um from sean o'malley because we all
want to like
keep going we all want to take the hits
and keep going
and we do we do it on a day-to-day basis
so to see this this little
i mean he had the green hair color this
little uh jolly rancher
he looked like a my little pony kind of
hopped up on jolly rancher candies
but to see him and i don't even say that
in a rude way i lo
you know i was fascinated it was it was
the it was one of the highlights of the
evening
people were chanting rocky at one point
um
to see him just keep going to see them
call the fight at the end
and not let him finish was a little
rough but uh
but man it was that was amazing
because we all want to take the hits and
keep going
and he did that hope you enjoyed that
video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one